[Music]
politico laying out the biden
administration's less can be more
approach for the media writing quote
three months in joe biden's white house
has settled on a firm press strategy
first
do no self-harm does this explain why
vice president kamala harris hasn't
addressed the border issue
is she avoiding possible backlash by
doing something
he'll react foxy contributor media
opinion columnist
for the hill joe concha joe we're trying
to grasp at a reason
why she seems disinterested in the
assignment she was given from the
president
what do you come up with well i see that
kamala harris brian in the last eight
months remember it was eight months ago
she was chosen as joe biden's running
mate
she has not done one press conference
and before you say well vice presidents
don't do press conferences yeah i'm old
enough to remember 2020 when
vice president pence did dozens of them
as a leader of the coronavirus task
force he was out there
taking questions from the press on a
daily basis so there goes that excuse
but look when you have a vice president
that's been tapped to fix the problem
that she has no interest in solving
that's an issue when she compared ice to
the kkk
as a senator as a candidate she would
have to answer for that i would think
during a press conference if a ducey or
a fisher asked that question
she would also have to explain why she
thinks that illegal border crossings
which we're seeing now
by the hundreds and thousands uh is
considered legal in her mind and that's
an argument that she made
as a senator and a candidate so here we
have a chronic complainer
it appears and not a doer based on her
actions because again
if she had to answer questions around
why are facilities
filled at 17 times the amount at the
border meanwhile we're hearing about
reports of abuse
of sexual assault politifact says that
they don't know the exact positivity
rate among migrants in terms of covid
testing
and a lot of these folks are being
released into the general population so
this is supposed to be the honest and
transparent
administration instead it's more acting
like pyongyang
in terms of media blackouts at the
border which would never be accepted
under the previous administration seems
like a couple of years ago it was just a
couple years ago when kamala harris had
that great rollout
and then when she was asked about issues
like healthcare and border security she
said one ridiculous thing after another
she couldn't last a primary she was
ill-prepared as if somebody
gave her a test and she forgot to study
nothing's changed
and i laugh when people analyze and say
well she was handed a hand grenade
not really do you think that mike pence
embraced the pant he would love getting
the pandemic portfolio
no but he embraced it because you got to
do big things if you're the second most
powerful person
in the country so biden defends harris
this way
when i served as vp i asked to be the
last person the president before big
decisions were made
and that bp is providing the same
counsel to me she's the last voice in
the room and never fails to speak the
truth
as we work to build our nation back
better then where is her policy
we heard some policies put into place
with mexico
honduras and guatemala about handling
the
the uh illegal immigration coming from
their countries
kamala harris should have been heading
that up
yeah brian she's the last one in the
room because she's not
at the border she isn't visiting a
border that she was put in charge of
what are we talking about now
three weeks ago and then we hear an
excuse a couple days later
from the white house press secretary
saying no actually the vice president is
in charge of diplomacy
okay again that means getting out and
seeing these people
not doing phone calls why haven't you
traveled to guatemala or nicaragua or
mexico
in terms of solving this problem and how
do you solve a problem at the border
when you can't grasp it
by talking to border officials by
talking to these people running these
migrant facilities
if you're not there and you don't see it
you can't fix it
so look this is a team biting biden
strategy that that seems to be playing
not to lose it was risk-averse during
the campaign
it's now the risk-adverse presidency
that only works for so long because at
some point
you're going to be judged on your
actions since this point the biden
administration has been
about a lot of words and spending a lot
of money but not a lot about actual
action when it comes to fixing crisis is
like we're seeing at the board
you know political rights too that you
know barack obama did between two ferns
used to do late night television did a
lot more interviews
and joe biden is we're not doing that
and a lot of people question whether
it's ron clayne running the country
or is susan rice running the country
because she's had a domestic policy
it doesn't look like either one of them
are taking the lead or hiding it well
joe koncha thanks so much